[Music]
hello good evening and welcome to
psytrek your sci-fi tv and movie channel
and i am this evening joined by
this idiot over here
tonight we are going to talk about
stargate and because the rumors
continue
um did a video a couple of nights ago
talking about how there is a room that
i've been told
that actually a couple of the producers
or the the guys that created
um or that they didn't create the
expanse did they they adapted the
expanse for tv um hawk ostby and uh
mark fergus have been tapped up to
look at stargate and to maybe put a
proposal forward for if they were
allowed to do stargate what would they
do
first start we'll talk about that matt
why are you looking at me sideways
you're not
so what did you what did you think about
this room for a start what jumps out are
you
well having watched the expanse i've not
seen all of it yet so i don't spoil any
of it
for the later seasons but having watched
it
knowing that these guys have worked on
it
gives me
lots of excited exciting feelings does
it make you warm in your trouser area
yes happy in my trousers yes
inappropriate humor to start the day
just knowing that
the guys involved in the expanse which
is a great
uh
show
if they're going to come in and do
stargate which is one of my favorite
shows
oh i don't know it just makes me feel
excited because the expanse is fantastic
i think it is an exciting possibility
and i think they'd give it a different
take i've had a few hateful messages
because some people are very much brad
or nothing
brad or bust
and i think you know i would i would ask
people if you're watching the video this
evening don't blame the messenger it's
not my fault
you don't need to i know actually 99 of
people don't but one or two idiots have
been they've been quite hateful towards
me it's not my fault one person called
me an effing liar because they say well
you said that it was about to get green
lit because well because it was when mgm
were in charge it was about to get
greenlit they got brad right to make
that script
and they thought as soon as amazon sale
went through that they'd be allowed to
make it and then amazon went no
um
they actually got thought that yeah
you know a couple of people have called
me a liar about this but another piece
of proof about this actually is james
bond
mgm were ready to go with rennie john
page as james bond i mean that was he
was the bookies number one favorite i
mean if you follow what the book you say
the bookies tend to know
um there was loads of stories about it
but then he signed on to do the saint
mgm thought that well it can still do it
it's fine it can do the same and do bond
and amazon went no we can't
so it's because they're very similar
characters and we need bond to be
special it's our flagship mgm product
you know venice on page can't do it so
it threw them back to the drawing board
they started thinking about idris elba
again
which is not i know for a fact that's
not what they want to do they want to go
for a young
pre double 07 bond and sort of do a
reboot and you know start again sort of
thing
so that just it's just the problem is
the same has happened with stargate
amazon have gone in and gone this is
[ __ ]
um and i had to start again but anyway
so
the rumors keep happening and they keep
bouncing around that maybe we'd be
looking at a hard reboot
all right so all right we've got a soft
reboot the soft reboot is like star trek
the next generation all right soft
reboot
same um same universe different
characters right
hard reboot is like everything that's
happened before
didn't happen
so i'm just going to say first straight
off the bat what is your gut feeling
if they were to do a hard reboot
initially
if anyone ever says hard reboot i'm just
like no
but
if it's done right
i'm open to it if it's done right
i don't they see the the the
problem i have with the hard reboot is
because there's
20 odd years of
existing
uh characters and stories
if they
do a hard reboot and then try and do
them again it's not gonna have the same
impact like if they try and do anubis
again
like that was amazing the first time
yeah it wouldn't be amazing the second
time same with the replicators uh well
maybe the replicas actually but
now i would say actually the replicators
is possibly a better example than anubis
because
you know they did the replicators to
death you could argue you know i think
really that because they were a good
body
yeah um anubis is only in like 12
episodes
true
something like maybe 16. something like
that it wasn't as many as i thought i
was i was googling it today because
somebody went
somebody i dropped a comment and saying
no anubis is frozen on the planet and
that kernel you're wrong you're on about
so i was like no we see anubis again
because they were they were commenting
on the our anubis video when they knew
this is a great guy we see anubis's
ascended part in the reckoning episodes
so i happen to notice yeah it's only 12
or something episode
with the replicators
if they were to do them again obviously
you have
the initial replicators the little bug
crawly things that
you never see anyone actually die
from them from the little boys
the the big thing with the replicators
was that they eventually evolved into
human
human-like form
yeah so they couldn't do it again
because we already know that's going to
happen if they if the replicator is
coming we go oh it's it's just a matter
of time before fifth comes back
yeah and
there'll be no sort of like theory
crafting like with a lot of tv shows
people theory crafting like well what
could happen what's gonna who we're
gonna see next
and it happens a lot with comic book
shows like the flash
um
people are always
like basically spoiling it for
themselves thinking oh uh reverse flash
is going to come back oh now we've got
godspeed or we've got savitar yeah
they're already pre-existing
which we have a lot with marvel movies
don't we we already know which is why
marvel marvel know that though and they
twist
stuff all the time don't they to sort of
like keep us guessing but
you see my problem has always been and i
and i wouldn't
if they weren't hard reboot
it it's not stargate right first start i
i make this argument that if they hard
reboot firefly and they just remake
firefly it's not firefly anymore it's
just a show called firefly
um it's a completely different show so
it might be brilliant it might be awful
but i'm not going to get excited about
it any more than i would any other show
i know nothing about because
it's just it's just happens to be called
stargate there will be a big circley
thing that they walk through to go to
other planets other than that we know
nothing about it so i'm not gonna get
excited about it i will get it'll it'll
just be okay interesting new show i'll
wait see what it's like
stargate by name only you know what i
mean
um
but the problem with stargate is
we had 17
years have it been only 17 years or 17
series 17 seasons and seasons don't say
serious for the love of god there's
three series 17 seasons when i say
series and americans get very angry at
me so
sorry
um 17 seasons uh
three uh two movies one seen in the
original movie
there's a lot happened and by the end of
sgu the humanity was very advanced
a lot it happened
it makes framing a new series quite hard
and for it to still be
stargating
yeah so how do you how do you how do you
start that new series even though
there's a there's been like 11 years now
since sgu finished
um
i i don't quite know how they how they
do that and how they create a new series
that basically isn't just star trek
you know in spaceships and things like
the whole joy of stargate wasn't it that
it could be real it could actually be
happening
but brad's already basically said that
in his series
they it would be
known the world would know about the
stargate because he said nothing else
makes sense and it's right nothing it
wouldn't make any sense for it to still
be a secret
yeah i'm surprised they never did done a
disclosure
in the run that we saw
honestly
um
yeah you are right we have got
17 seasons of all of this stuff that's
happened it is going to be incredibly
difficult for amazon to come up with a
good story
they'd have to do another like sgu type
of thing i think where it would have to
be a series in the comments guys tell us
what you think
but um it would have to be some sort of
series it was a very closed storyline so
it exists in the universe
of stargate but we i don't think we
could see another like sg-1 type series
where
it's you know a big broad sort of series
where anything can happen
because so much has already happened
they're just going to end up pissing on
cannon every five minutes
they won't be able to write stories
because
there's so much stuff they have to
remember so they'd have to do something
like
sgu or something like that where there's
a team
and it's in this universe but it's
trapped somewhere
well i made a comment in one of our
previous live streams
um
that
it's been 11 odd years
we're pretty stupid maybe we've lost
some of the technology
the asgard core
it probably just got blown up because it
almost got blown up in the first
10 minutes i was having it the first
time so it probably happened again
um
i mean the actual knowledge that we've
gained
that's still going to be there but the
tech we could lose it something could
have happened um maybe
your theory of the furlings
you know ambassadors of the galaxy
coming back to say no you too advanced
they could just take all the technology
away at humans
no more asgard weapons
yeah and you would pass too quickly
yeah yeah yeah
you're advancing too quickly gonna kill
yourselves
so
we're gonna take it away
yeah
maybe
um i like that idea um
or potentially
we are super advanced now
but
power corrupts
what if
we are now we are technically the
villain but there is a branch
of
what we would probably say is the sgc
the good guys
fighting against
not fighting
not you know they're causing trouble
somehow yeah yeah
that that could be right and then
there's an element within the sgc that
are fighting against the corruption
which we saw in stargate in sg-1 i loved
the episode i loved the political
episodes in star game which added to the
realism to me you know like senator
kinsey comes along he's trying to shut
the program because it costs too much
and the risks and i'm like this would
happen government some [ __ ] senator
would come along and go oh well i don't
know about this and you know and would
or make out that he knows better than
everybody else um and we'll try and shut
it down or something so yeah if the
government stepped in
there was now a civilian thing yeah yeah
you know the sgc were always rosy and
the good guys weren't they but you know
in reality
we know governments aren't always to be
trusted
really
the sgc wasn't all that good
the only people that were good
well they were all good but the driving
force behind that being good would have
been daniel jack
and hammond and in later seasons landry
and um
what's his name ben brown
mitchell mitchell
like they were the dr i would say are
the driving forces of being good because
they were corrupt sg members we saw that
in the episode
um where jack
actually an id or something else
yeah so as an organization it's not
necessarily they are the good guys
um
so now they're gone
something could have happened it could
be now a corrupt organization
you like you say though power corrupts
absolute power crops absolutely and we
would be
the toughest
fleet in the in the galaxy that we know
of
yeah you know with the asgard weapons
um
i think it would be obviously the
boosting lines we've got to touch us
sorry
it'd be much like how the old roads rose
to power they they stole they stole
technology obviously we didn't steal it
we acquired it but the the act of
getting it i don't think matters the
fact that they had the technology so
quickly
they then become corrupt i mean they
were always kind of crocodile evil but
they become more corrupt especially with
the sarcophagus technology
like
it just
in my head it makes sense that there
would be
we we would essentially be the bad guys
because when
i think
narratively
there's a lot of
there's a lot of shows that that
basically
explore the idea that the government is
corrupt now
yeah well i mean that's starting
yeah nobody trusted government anymore
do they we just don't
yeah um
and by extension that might might um
people might not then trust the military
so they could be like civilian branches
of
a a kind of a military branch but not
u.s military
maybe yeah
there's lots of ways they could do it
but i still think
it's star trek rather than stargate
which is that's always me
excuse me yeah
um
right so one
so so what i'm told about what's going
on at amazon is that basically this
project has been completely gone
straight back to the drawing board
that they had several mgm were working
on several ideas including an ancient
prequel series and they were developing
um story arcs now these things would
work and doing all these ideas of what
they thought amazon wanted and then when
amazon actually got control they went no
uh you're not doing that we're not
having that so everything's gone back to
the drawing board these these two guys
hawk ostb
i want mine i think i should be named
hawk from now
um or eagle
i don't know i was flapping my arms like
but anyway and mark fergus i think or
just mockingjay
mockingjay
[Laughter]
um
i would love to see
um well it seems to me very much that
they're going back to the drawing board
i mean bringing these guys in they're
not being these guys have been brought
in to write a script from what i'm being
told they've been brought in to
basically say right okay if you were to
do stargate tomorrow what would you do
and that they've got a blank canvas
pretty much
um the only thing i've been told is
they've they have been told it should
stay in canon so wouldn't be a hard
reboot but
even that's up for discussion
they have got a blank and so what would
you do with it which i like the idea i
like the idea that they've just gone
you know two guys that are very good at
what they do and you know like we trust
you to come back with it doesn't assume
it'll get made it may never see the
light of day but i do like the idea i do
like at least that my favorite tv show
i'm just gonna put in this much serious
thought into it they're not just going
with the first thing
you know um they're serious about
wanting to make a decent
product
yeah
i mean
you've got
you've got the possibility of
well atlantis was was successful
sgu is debatable whether that was
successful i mean i i think people are
coming down here now
i thought it was i thought it was good
lots of other people did
um
but anyway atlantis was successful
everyone can agree on that yeah maybe
they could go down the route of
keeping it in canon but
they're somewhere else so not
necessarily on earth they're not in
pegasus they're not on the destiny
they're somewhere else what about the
iodine galaxy where the asgard lit yeah
what about
that
as many planets as you can think of
there's more galaxies
yeah
so they could go anywhere
and it could it could be something like
they're they're trapped
which was the initial thing with
stargate atlantis they couldn't get back
yeah
um
and sgu
and sgu obviously we never saw the
conclusion to that
so they could go down that route again
um i just wouldn't want to see it
centered around the ancients this time
i'd like to see it somewhat
not if they're doing ancient series i'd
like to be as well as something else i'd
i'm happy to see an ancients prequel
series i think it would be brilliant
i'd love to see an ancients yeah an
entrance prequel hundred percent but if
there was
in a year or two if the main showed as
well
yeah if they were doing the main show
i'd like it to be something completely
separate to the ancients yep um because
i think they they did rely a little bit
too heavily on it towards the end
and it'd be nice to go back to the
the original story you know
adventure of the week go for the
stargate see what you can discover
find technology uh and so and and try
and
get technologies to be whoever the big
bad is in this particular galaxy or
location that you're in now yeah yeah
you know i'd be okay with that
um
so
the downside though of this
rumor
that amazon are willing to
completely scrap all of it and i
remember brad wright himself said on the
25th anniversary he especially did it
with richard dean anderson
that he doesn't think his script will
ever see the light of day
um so he you know we can infer from that
he doesn't even think he's gonna get
made
um because i was actually told not long
before that that amazon was seriously
still considering it he was in the
driving seat
but then
there were voices within amazon that
didn't didn't like the way he'd gone
with it and it seems like those voices
went out in the end anyway
but that if this room is true about hawk
and mark
um then that means no brad right
or does it
yeah it doesn't necessarily mean brad
wright's not going to be involved if
they're if they're going to be
writing and producing it or even if it's
i think they're just writers aren't they
or did they produce as well they're kind
of they produced they they were
executive producers and producers for
the expanse
so if they if they were just doing that
doesn't mean
brad can't show ron
yeah
um and i and i think that brown's rights
have not said anything as far as i know
publicly either way
um but he's definitely not so even if
his script doesn't get made i i would
say bring him in as a showrunner it
makes complete sense to me
um honestly these guys didn't show run
the expanse
you know they just they developed it
they produced it they wrote some
episodes for it
you know
so i've got i i don't think any reason
why that but if if brad wright was not
involved in this at all
does it only matter
well
if they do a good show
doesn't matter right who cares if brad
wright isn't involved sadly i mean you
know i don't want to put it that way but
i think there's a lot of there's a lot
of emphasis being put on we want
stargate but we also want brad right
what we can all agree on is we want
stargate yeah whether or not brad's
involved that's not up to us but we hope
he is but if he's not
we're still gonna watch it
it's targeting we'll still give the
chance i mean i would i mean you know
the first thing if it's rubbish the
first thing a lot of people say was well
you should have put my dragon charge
yeah
see i think they would they they will
still have brad involved to some
capacity because they know
that we want brad so whether he's just
throwing it for the first season
or his name's on the credits somewhere
like co-produced by brad right just
having his name on there will appease
fans and then they can slowly phase him
out if they really want to
once he knows
how it's going see one story that i did
here and it's i have heard it a couple
of times was that amanda tapping was
going to be
potentially come back as show runner
and she's never showed showrunned
showed runed
showrunner on any show previously but
she has been exec producers she has
directed she's she's quite a well
respected director
um
it would just be the next step up for
her show that she runs at the moment
salem's something or other is coming to
an end
so the timing might be fortuitous
um and i've been told that that has been
something that's been discussed and even
discussed potentially with amanda
tapping i mean brad wright even talked
about her coming back directing and what
have you but maybe she could come back
in a more
formal you know actually as the show
runner and then i think if they don't
come on with brad for whatever reason if
they don't if they decide we're not
going with brad
um
they would have to bring in somebody
from the original or fans will
i think
again guys you say yes or no in the in
the comments
if there's no brad
will you be tempted not to watch
the the
the series
so would you would you watch the series
yes anyway or would you no
not watch the series i will just see how
many knows fly up because i think it
might be a few
there are some people that are just like
brad right or nothing
yeah
that's the problem when it comes to
[Music]
reviving a show
you want it to be exactly the same as it
was
yeah and yeah brad was the in the
driving seat for the entirety of
everything we know about stargate but
if you have a refreshment
that's nearly a bad thing
um
because he knows the story
yeah
i mean if amanda tapping
did become the showrunner
i i don't think fans would have an issue
with that
bradford would def would give his
blessing he'd do it publicly um
and everyone would be on board with it
if they
if they kind of just pushed him out
and he
was still tweeting that he was still
going on about his script that he really
wants to get out there i think that
would
hurt the new show's chances i can't i
can't see brad doing that to be honest i
think it would be if i wasn't if i was
an executive at amazon
and for whatever reason if i didn't want
brad involved and i wanted to shut him
up
you'd probably manage happening because
he's not going to say anything negative
about the show or i might just happen
but i don't think brad wright would do
that anyway
i don't think brad white will say
anything negative about the show even if
it's not
the man's tapping he doesn't seem like
that sort of person to me i've i've
spoken to him a couple of times he's not
an unkind spiteful person
i think he'd
just go okay that's business that's you
know that's
that's the industry we live in and
that's you know
so i don't think he would either way
anyway to be honest but
um
but i i could see amanda tapping doing
it and i think she's got the skills to
do it if they wanted to
but i i suspect they won't know i
suspect they'll bring in somebody new i
think they want to kurtzman this thing
with star trek you know they want to
bring in something completely new and go
in a different direction with it and
it'll still feel like stargate but it'll
be going a different direction i
think um
whereas canon is
there in the background but they don't
worry about it too much
yeah you know i think that's where
they're going to go
there's an argument to be made when
going back to the hard reboot cut side
of things there's been 11 years since
the the show's been on the air it
started airing in the 90s people who
are generally watching news series is
now
like stranger things they were really
young they weren't even born when
stargate would like first came out so
the chances of them actually
going back and watching all the original
seasons is very very small there are
going to be the outliers who will do it
but they're going to need to cater to
the new audience and explain things in a
to to
explain who these characters are where
they came from so how reboot would get
around that yeah because it's going to
be very difficult to start a new series
and say oh yeah this is a series
continuing from 10 years ago when you
were three years old
here's a good point um they're not going
to go back and necessarily watch it all
again so
if you can't if you don't worry about
catering to that audience but
i always think that with sci-fi that and
that's and that's why star trek confuses
me so much under kurtzman with discovery
and and strange new worlds really
because that's very at risk that's all
you peeing on canon
sci-fi fans tend to get a bit anal about
these things
they do tend to be a bit
they they actually remember
the canon and they get quite annoyed i
mean that don't get me wrong i i think
canon's important but i don't go crazy
on it i'm not like one of these people
go well that's that's the wrong color
and i'm like i don't go that far but i
do think the history of what happens in
the in the in the series the
particularly the seminal points
you know if you have a war with the
romulans you shouldn't just forget about
it in discovery
you know or
spock shouldn't just all of a sudden
have a new sister and things like that
so if stargate calls back and they word
hard reboot it and o'neill
and you know all of a sudden
his son wasn't dead or something that
would be a problem for me because i'm
like no that's an important point of the
character
i wouldn't care if he was a black guy i
wouldn't care um i was going to say i
wouldn't care if he was a woman then
that might have gone a bit far but i
wouldn't care about that sort of thing
but i would care if they changed
who o'neill was you know that's the
point that that is the big point of
o'neill
you know and i'd like to see him still
wise cracking and put you know but um
see i think they could still bring
o'neill back
it wouldn't be richard dean anderson
though they could bring a new character
and have him be jack o'neill and in
canon explain it as that's the clone
that's the clone yeah his his clone
could come back and that would be fine
i would think that a little silly myself
but it's it's in canon so why not yeah
um
there's lots of things they could do i
hope they don't do and i'm afraid they
might because this you know this game
timekeepers is coming out
and one thing i was told got six or nine
months ago was that um
and this came from amazon actually that
they wanted to
create the series in and around
um on a multi-format so that the game
would become common
and so that and then and he's and this
guy actually told me i don't speak to
him anymore unfortunately he doesn't
work in the industry anymore but and he
told me at the time look at the
storyline of timekeepers and that'll
tell you
a lot about what they're planning to do
with stargate in the future
and timekeepers is
jumping through time
um time is broken they use the stargate
to jump through time because of solar
flare or some nonsense and
that's the and this is and that will
tell you a lot about which leads me on
to think
they'll do a timelines version of this
or a multiverse version
so they'll say it's they'll they'll say
it's not a hard reboot even though
everything's different
because
it's a different universe
this time changed and they need to fix
it but they can't fix it they can only
fix it a certain way to the way that
amazon now are envisioning it yeah so
it'll be a jj abrams
version of stargate
the kelvin timeline
and i hate that idea
i i think it's lazy
um
but it's a way around a lot of the
problems
and there are problems that if they do a
new series it is going to be hard that's
why it's taking so long whatever anybody
else says all these videos and things
that are coming up saying why is star
gate taking so long and a lot of things
it is partly because mgm is a mess that
is true
but a big problem with why we haven't
got anything to know something is they
don't know what to do with it it's hard
to to come up with a storyline that
makes sense because there's so much
before it
the easy thing to do is do a hard reboot
that's the easy thing to do
or a different universe so if they did
do a hard reboot
they just scrapped and started again
is that a problem
it's a problem for us as
as people who have watched stargate but
new people coming into the
franchise it wouldn't be an issue for
them they wouldn't care
i think the general audience was
stargate is actually pretty old i think
it's
isn't it like 40 to 60 year olds yeah
that's gonna be the demographic for the
original that's where we are now yeah
i'm i you know i watched it from the
start i'm 44 years old now yeah and i
watched it first time around
okay so if you did a hard reboot
would you have the gold in it
is that where you'd start
from the movie i don't i don't think
they could could they
but going back to what i was saying
earlier having the exact
you i guess you could it just wouldn't
you just they couldn't do the same once
they couldn't start with apophis and
then go on to
um
a new soca and then go on to anubis like
you couldn't do it in the same order
no i guess you could have the same gold
i mean if they start with ball
do you have to have any of those guys
though you just have the gold as a
species and if how have totally new
new ones or would you start again with
ra
i mean you could they could just
have to go but not have them be a
egyptian god at all they could just have
completely different names
yep i would accept a reboot of space
1999 that was ages ago and only had two
seasons but stargate i've run it for a
very long time and no one has forgotten
it here which is a very very good point
at the end of the day um
you can reboot things that are old
because nobody watch it like lost in
space to be fair to me
i actually quite like that
kind of bit boring at times but
i didn't have a problem with them doing
a hard reboot because the series is so
old
you know why not yeah and there is
stories about them doing um a reboot of
like um a space odyssey 2001 and we're
making it for serious again i have no
problem with that a movie from 40 50
years ago
i have no problem with that but
the series
it's not that old you know it's
so i i think um yeah mr rio has a really
good point though
um i will always read out um super chats
thank you guys yeah i think there's
there's older there's there's older
uh franchises for sure when you've got
star trek you're stargate they're
they're older than stargate
yeah basically rebooted star trek though
and it hadn't been off our screens that
long
yeah and disney has basically rebooted
star wars
love it or hate it
i think they have
the pre the sequels
as a fan of star wars i absolutely hate
but the series
the mandalorian boba fett
obi-wan
fantastic
and that's brought in a lot more people
who are now fans of star wars as a
result and i think that's good for the
franchise
but aren't they just telling different
stories within the universe it's not
that's more of a soft reboot isn't it
there
i mean i wish they'd they'd stick to a
timeline
so i don't have to get a bloody
choreography or you know
i have to ever think about where does
this fit in the thing
and andors coming out that generally
took me about 20 minutes to figure out
where it fit in the universe um yeah
just stories
we could we could see stargate do the
same thing and have stories from
outside the you know to have different
we could have jaffa stories or something
like that that's wrong doing a story
about the jaffa it sounds like i'm
saying something dirty but i'm not
um
but wouldn't it be stargate
is it a big enough
i mean
i think this is the best sci-fi tv but
could is it big enough to get away with
doing that
i don't think a jafar
series would work
it might be later on
it could do but i don't think early on
it would work just because
people won't
have the attachments to jafar and i
don't think there's many stories you can
tell did you find that aren't already
told by the guard
anyway
yeah
so now i think they would have to if
they did a reboot
a hard reboot and they started again
they would have to go back and basically
remake the original movie as well
or
they would start off with a movie like
this rumor that kurt russell might make
a sequel to the movie i i'm going to
reiterate again i don't think that rumor
is true people seem to keep thinking
that i've said that that rumor is true
and it's happening it's not
i i heard that they've talked to kurt
russell and thought about it but i
actually said in the video quite clearly
i don't think this was true i don't
think it'll happen and that the rumor
about them talking to him might be true
but they talked to him five years ago so
we know it's true
i just don't think the film will ever
happen i don't i don't think they'll do
it but they could
do a reboot and just ignore the tv
series
in which case the goldworld are still a
threat and they just do it a different
way
but the gold were quite different
in the original movie so do they get rid
of the snakehead thing
and go back to
the original version the gold
or when they look more like the asgard
when they go yeah definitely
yeah um
um but the other i mean a lot of the
story it was it was almost identical but
you know like the way ra was
was different you know it was a little
bit different
i would say it's a lot more fleshed out
in the tv series myself but
um do they just ignore the tv series and
go back to the original movie
and and could you imagine
what most gators will say if they do
that
yeah i can see it now if if they
rebooted it and it was completely
different
everyone would be up in arms
yeah i'm thinking more i'm just trying
i'm playing devil's africa by thinking
about how amazon will see it
that
they're not going to be they're going to
be thinking long term about this
they're going to want a franchise that's
going to last a while
yeah
catering towards people who are
old
yeah and and they want this to be the
front they want this to be their star
trek
that's what they would ideally like they
think they've got the sleeping giant
sci-fi
now and they want it to be their star
trek
yeah no so they are thinking long term
definitely
see i think it could be
it could be good
it it could be fantastic a reimagining
of
everything we've seen before
i'm thinking of this as as we're talking
about it
just just thinking of how
it could go
what it could look like with the current
with the budgets that amazon would
probably give to the cgi that we've got
the technology we've got now
and the storytelling
now is
in script television is a lot better
than it was back then yeah i think it
could be fantastic yeah
i always think about thing because one
of the things i've always said is
they're not going to do a hard reboot
and we've actually seen the evidence
that because
they
spoke to roland
and he said roland emmerich they were
talking about doing the movie
um and they're going to be that's all
their evidence to say why they were they
this conversation about this kurt
russell movie has actually happened but
i think it was a while ago to be honest
as well i was going to say i think that
conversation happened about 18 months
ago
um but anyway um because roland emmerich
said about yeah they spoke to me about
it and but i got very much the
impression that the audience is what
mattered so i'm not interested
and we know that happened because he
said it publicly
um but
that was with mgm
okay what that was not a conversation
with amazon
so yeah and everything that they said to
mgm
everything anything that was said to mgm
now doesn't matter and even if it was
written in stone then that stone's been
destroyed
yeah it's yeah it's completely gone and
see even it is seems to be though that
right so a lot of things i've said about
what amazon have said about stargate as
well and stuff is stuff that was being
told to mgm
it's now seems very clear that amazon
were lying to mgm
yeah amazon were telling mgm
executives and things because that would
filter down stuff lots of things they
just wanted to hear that they were
telling mgm yeah you're amazing they're
going to come in we're just going to be
like a customer you're still going to be
able to do your marvelous do whatever
you want to do we're not going to impose
on mgm we want we love mgm we love your
creativity we want to protect you not
destroy you
and that
was very clearly not true because within
a couple of weeks of
um the amazons it finally going through
the ftc
um
amazon's hammer came down and the two
chief executives left
um were retired
um and
all of the different departments under
mgm came under the equivalent amazon
executives so they took over stockholm
they got rid of a load of mgm employee
any employee that was on a short-term
contract they got rid of them
um you know the hacker came down so it's
very sort of that it seemed to me that
amazon was just saying the right things
because they wanted it to go through the
ftc as quickly as possible and they knew
that if the mgm employees were on board
and not kicking up a force it would go
through easy
yeah because their excuses if i was
covered cove had stopped us from doing
it it's just bs
because they knew about the covered
impact two years ago
they're not stupid
and covered was pretty much towards the
end by the time
the deal actually went through
look at this shelley who runs our
facebook group who is amazing and bought
you right i'm jealous of a cup i
designed i designed that freaking cup
and shelley's bought it off side
dashtrack.com and it's freaking gorgeous
i really really want it
i'm going to buy myself a mug um but
thank you for the contribution and thank
you as always for your support shelley
you're amazing
dodging traffic please
please don't get run over i need you to
look after the facebook group
um
but but yeah so was i saying so yeah um
so yeah amazon lied they just they just
lied um i'm surprised there wasn't an
investigation afterwards
well now because it's
in dc they didn't
it was no formal anything formally that
was agreed they
they haven't breached
it was just conversations like informal
conversations we'll do this we'll do
that there's not no promises that ever
have to be kept
yeah so that's that's the problem with
these mergers they know exactly which
well how to say certain things to get
you one side don't they they know
if they don't have it written down on
this contract they don't have to
legally
but but morally
yeah that's the problem is that you
can't investigate moral
stuff or informal conversations that
just happen to happen between two people
you know it's just like oh yeah this is
what we want to do
but now they're just saying it is what
we wanted to do promise but now because
they're covered we can't
so then you know that's it in it so
ah
excuse the code thing ever every company
has got is using it for
like their fridge the fridge stops
working in the staff room and they blame
it on covert yeah
it's so stupid
it's just the same
i'm sorry but again they knew the
country the world shut down for 12
months or 18 months
they're not thick
they knew that there was then going to
be an economic crisis they knew that
what was going to happen you know um so
no it will be used as an excuse but
them saying we didn't see it coming
not true not even remotely i'm not
having that
yeah
so
a hard reboot i think we can agree then
that it's a head and a heart situation
for me like head and heart
head and heart situation for me my heart
says i don't want a hard reboot okay i
love i don't want him to wipe out what
came
before you know i want it to i don't
want to just to ignore it that's not no
it's wrong
but my head says oh god it might be a
better show if they do
if you give new writers the chance to
just do something new and without having
the chains of
what come before wrapped around their
neck it might make a better show
might might not
yeah um so it's a head and a heart
decision but heart always wins over the
head you know it does when there's that
pretty girl that heart goes oh i really
like her but your head goes
yeah she's you know i think she might be
a bit easy and i think she fancies my
brother more than she likes me
you're hot you still hit on it you still
try and get her to go to the cinema and
you still because you know your heart
wins out it always does
um i think that might be the problem
we
we might we was we want
we we definitely want
a continuation
our heads are thinking yeah maybe a hard
reboot will be good and then
and then amazon might be doing it the
opposite way to us and then they'll
they'll go with their heads they'll do a
hard reboot
it'll be fantastic we might like it
but what if it doesn't do well
that is stargate done
yeah that will be it will be the end of
starting here but i mean that's true
either way if they go hard reboot or not
hard reboot if um it's if it doesn't
succeed
i very much doubt we'll never see it
again
saying that discovery didn't do well
um and
it spawned strange new worlds which is
done brilliantly
so yeah
so who knows
i suppose it depends on what
so we've got to remember as well amazon
and streaming services don't care about
viewing figures they care about
subscribers
and if enough people say i subscribe to
amazon for stargate they'll keep it
you know it's the one of the main
reasons why i'm absolutely certain the
expanse is going to come back it doesn't
get great viewing figures
but enough people
adore it you know it's got that cult
status that
you know people actually will say if
asked if you
if we bring back the expanse will you
subscribe to amazon prime and they say
yes
you know yeah i won't watch anything
else i just want to watch out but i just
wanna that's what stargate that's what
they want stargate to be for them
like star trek is for paramount plus
name
there's a lot of people that just
watched paramount plus and we say this
every week but they watch pyramid plus
because of star trek
you know
netflix
got it
all wrapped up they've got loads of
shows that people will only watch
oh you getting everything because of
that like stranger things umbrella
academy
yeah
lots of cool seriously
yeah
i mean things like stranger things is
quite a rarity because it's actually
very commercially successful it's very
very popular
um
[Music]
a lot of their other series necessarily
aren't but
yeah
so here's one of the guys actually
jungli has just jumped in there i think
this channel is nothing but rooms
he's one of the guys that was sending
all the messages and they were just
going on um anyway
so
yeah so i think that's where we're at at
the moment
i don't know
whether i
want
i think what we want is irrelevant as
well i think an element of that i think
brad wright could come in and just do a
bad series anyway
yeah
um and i think whatever happens i think
you're 100 right that if whatever
happens if it's not a very good series
it'll be that it will be the end of
stargate it'll it'll die and maybe i
mean i feel sure amazon executives know
that
and at the end of the day they're going
to spend 150 million quid plus maybe on
this series nobody does that without
trying to make sure this is a good
product anyway nobody nobody
intentionally makes a bad series today
so
they're not going to go let's make a
pile of crap but nobody alike nobody
does that but
i mean
just
thinking more um
how i wanted to play out
they'd bring
in my head they'd bring stargate back
it'd be a continuation of what we know
and love
if it does well
fantastic if it doesn't
okay
then they can do a hard reboot then they
can explore all of the reboot in the
movie and reboot the series as
um
a re-imagination reimagining of it and
if that does well
fantastic i'll watch it
because it's still starting
yeah
but i said i'd want i'd want the
continuation first
i'd want something in canon first
yeah i i i think that's how i if it was
me and i was in charge i would be saying
we need something in continuation of
canon a main series
an sg-1 style something or other
and then
you know and then go and and then we'd
love a prequel we'd love something else
we'd love some little seed
did i act i actually think is going to
happen though and this is just my
opinion well it's my opinion based on
what i've been told and obviously based
what we know about how all of these
series are made
but i think they will go the star wars
direction of like the mandalorian book
of effect and all the other tv series
that are coming and they will do
10 episodes well we know 100 is going to
be 10 episodes 10 or 12 episodes in a
run
but each series we might have two or
three series a year
but each series would be like a
different chapter in a book and might be
aimed on different characters or based
on slightly different storylines
we might even see just like a one-off
ancient storyline that then feeds into
something else in a more modern i think
that's what they'll do
yeah
that that that works well with the
timekeepers theory as well what you just
said
yeah different different theory
different series
in different times so you'd have your
ancients prequel which you all want
you'd have something to do with a group
you'd have something to do with
something in the future a new threat
yeah
i would love to see um just a one series
ten episodes where it starts off with
the um destiny getting launched right so
the series for me is destiny getting the
first two or three episodes are all
about why they built the destiny
actually constructing it and then
launching it and then the series ends
with
those
crew
um because you know they said apparently
in the comics they're saying some of the
crew that actually built ancients built
it were actually in stasis on the
destiny they woke up and they basically
started the sdu crew so that's what i
would love to see that 10 episodes 10 or
12 episodes
start with the launch ends with them
actually saving eli
you know if that would be a cool little
cool little c season you know i've got
to stop saying series on my season that
would be serious because i'll be
standalone but that could be so cool um
but that wouldn't i don't think you
could start the series with that it'd
have to be only hardcore fans to watch
that
as well
and that you're not bringing in new fans
for that is what i'm saying
so
you couldn't you couldn't start a series
with that but you could say two or three
in
you know particularly if you did this
like like chapters in a book sort of
idea where you can jump between
characters and stories but they all sort
of intertwine with each other
um i think that'd be awesome i'd watch
that i don't know i didn't
i'd like to see
an episode of three episodes or a whole
season of as you say the destiny
uh because in the in the back to destiny
comics
it did explain a few things
they've got the ancients that were on
board were engineers and they weren't
actually meant to be there destiny was
launched prematurely
oh yeah i think i think by accident
whilst they were still on board someone
had pressed a button and then they were
like fine widgets against stasis i must
touch red button
so that would be that'd be so cool i
don't think eli then inadvertently woke
one of them up and then woke up the
others who then like knocked them out
and whatever
um
but that also brought in one of my
favorite pieces of of law
which isn't canon and i really want it
to be you know the communication stones
yeah one of the ancients in the
throwaway comic goes
oh we just we we just use those as kids
toys
the most important thing in the world to
us
um
yeah i just think that would be a really
cool series i'd love to see that
um
because it could start with as you say
the
we could see the destiny was launched
and stuff like that and they could flash
it out a little bit more and it can end
with
eventually eli and everyone getting
saved um
do you think i think the saddest thing
for me though if they did if they didn't
do if they did do a hard reboot
the thing that i would
love to see i would love to see daniel
come back i'd love to see michael shanks
come back i'd love to see general carter
i don't think i don't want to see series
with these characters as main characters
but i'd love to see him come back in
little bit part you know general carter
as the leader of the sgc or something
like that would be great and if we get a
hard reboot we're not going to get that
and i think that would be the thing i
i would be most disappointed by you know
i'd love to see richard dean anderson
just one more time you know
um
but
it's a catch-22 though isn't it because
we always want with the new series we we
want it to be like the old series but we
also demand that it's new and different
because if it's like the old series
we'll just go well it's just the same as
the original series
we don't know what we want
and they don't know what they what what
we want
we're like
they don't know what we want so it's
hard for them but it's hard for us
watching in the background just being
like make us something good no not like
that
not like that not like that not like
that
whatever they do somebody will think
somebody will do a hate video on on a on
youtube months before it comes out
saying that it's going to be woke pile
of crap anyway
um before it's even been released so
that's going to happen there's nothing
we can do about it
um where are you finding these comics um
kevin mcgabe just commented i found the
back to destiny comics i just literally
just typed in
uh back to destiny pdf free there's a
website it's full of ads so if like if
you've got an ad blocker use that
but it's
it was free i didn't pay for it
yeah
um i bought them
yeah they are on amazon you can buy them
but
they weren't very much when i bought
them but i think they're quite expensive
because they're quite collectibles no
um but i but i bought them about 10
years ago i bought them years ago i
bought them not long after they came out
so uh i don't even think they're
released like
like openly in the uk
so i i got i'm seeing them in the uk
united states i think
you can't buy physical copies on amazon
you can only buy the kindle versions
how i bought physical but i bought
physical copies years ago and i don't
think i bought it from amazon actually i
think i bought it from a comic
book website
things planet probably would have done
them years ago
i can't remember when i was it was so
long ago i bought them but um i say that
kind of been 10 years ago
seven or eight years ago somewhere
anyway yeah i think it was like 2016
they come out yeah it was when it came
out i bought so um but but but yeah i
mean they were great well i was just i'm
just such a geek but i listened to all
those stories that they did as well on
them i think that they're coming back
now those audio stories that they did
they were great as well yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna purchase them
but you know
let's see what they do at the end of the
day we don't know what they're gonna do
like like like young whatever the hell
his name is i don't know
the pratt you mentioned earlier
he's not a practice a lovely human being
i'm sure jungling mentioned earlier this
that we know we're talking about rumors
and we are and the problem is we're
going to hear no more rumors chances are
and all of these things they could go
into a meeting amazon in six months time
and have all these different options
in front of them and they can just go
now we're not doing any of it
or now i tell you what we're gonna do
something completely different
and then and and green light it the next
day and we'll hear about it officially
the next day because that's how these
things work unfortunately
um
nothing is definite until the decision
is made
yeah and as we've already seen
you know
mgm had a product that they wanted
um
i i was told that they'd only done that
they only sort of like were pushing
trying to push through um stargate as
quickly as they could because they
were trying to get more money out of
amazon basically
um or more money at the sale because it
would be more valuable as a as an
operational franchise
rather than just an intellectual
property
and it was only because of covid we
don't have stargate now
know um even brad wright says we were we
were
five sherlocks were locked we were ready
to go
you know we were nearly there
we had the pilot script
covered hit
you know should we should be on our
third season of stargate now
yeah
if we haven't had covered
um
but now amazon have completely put the
cardboard
so
let's see what happens
so
instant chat as always young matthew
um
i'll let you speak this time so that's
good
you did
i only told you
once
you've done really well and there will
be a shut up mat t-shirt available on
side as truck.com if it's when i get
around to i'm going to do it this
weekend
got away from me
um it doesn't even take that long i
don't remember being such a lazy ass but
um i will get a few more designs on
there shortly um to to to try and you
know get sales so
um but anyway guys everyone that's
watched tonight and everyone has
commented in the side chat particularly
guys that have done that nice little
super chats for us thank you so much the
contribution really helps the channel um
i hope to one day not have to go to work
at nine o'clock tomorrow morning
um and you know actually i would love to
be able to do this a little bit more um
thing but i i can't do that without
money and um and my wife won't let me
unless we make money so unfortunately
i'd love to do this for free but i can't
so every little bit of help you guys
give really really means that we can
keep going
thank you matt for giving us your time
this evening
it's been a pleasure as always
we freaking love it um i will announce
while we guys go on i'm going to be
starting a video a live video once a
week on a wednesday night with my old
mate dave
um
where we talk about whatever the hell we
want to talk about i used to have a
channel years uh well i used to have a
channel called the machine a lot of you
guys will know me from there and regular
subscribers and we're going to start
doing that again on a wednesday um
not doing anything in particular you
know but just whatever subject interests
us we're going to start with
facts that we find out that you go what
that that sounds so ridiculous that
can't be true but ah
and that's going to be our first video
hopefully next week
um
so that's that's an announcement [ __ ]
and that will be on the sidetrack sides
channel so please go over to the side
sides channel and subscribe now there
should be a link in the description
but i rushed a bit today so i haven't
actually checked so um
thank you again matt thank you everybody
we will see you very soon
thank you very much sir i appreciate it
but actually it should be in the
description
guys thank you have a lovely evening as
always please stay safe say goodbye matt
goodbye matt
look at you you look you managed to look
at the camera well done
[Music]
you